It's my great pleasure to
introduce
Professor Abishek Gupta from the
University of Washington
where he's leading the
weird lab, right?
And
yeah, he focuses on foundation models
for robotics and reinforcement learning.
And we are super excited
to hear from this amazing work with
today's
topic simulation for robotic
manipulation without the pain. So yeah,
the the stage is yours Abishek.
So
thank you here. Thanks for the kind
invite and I'm looking forward to
talking to you all a bit about um
about some of the work we've been
working on around simulation for
robotics. So
uh um
uh as Oier kind of alluded to, my group
is called the weird lab, the Washington
Embodied Intelligence and Robotics
Development Lab.
And they told me it is okay. So this is
the name we chose. And so uh these are a
lot of my students. They're the ones who
did all the work and so I just wanted to
highlight them up front.
Um okay. So the goal of our group in
general um abroad is to deploy robots in
the messy unstructured environments,
right? So I'm generally lazy person. I
don't like to do any work. And I want my
robots to all do the work, right? So if
I have a kids playroom, I want all of it
to be cleaned up by robot. If I have my
kitchen doesn't look this clean, but if
it was,
um I'd like it to be cleaned up by uh by
a robot, right? So I don't want to I
want to think about settings which are
more messy, unstructured, unexpected,
right? And so you can't use the the
classical paradigm
um of sense plan act, which has been
used in robotics for the last 50, 60
years.
And so
um you know, the the fundamental premise
of what we think about is is robot
learning, right? And so we
uh we typically have this sense plan act
paradigm in robotics, right? So we start
by sensing the world, doing state
estimation, then think about doing
planning,
uh which is like modeling, and then, you
know, control or planning. Uh and then
finally, you execute things on the robot
with like
um with a low-level controller. And so,
this is the typical sense-plan-act
paradigm.
But, for every domain, you have to do a
bunch of engineering. You have to bunch
of um cost engineering. You have to do a
bunch of model engineering, right? Or
primitive engineering. And um you know,
the fundamental theme I'm going to kind
of keep going back to is I'm super lazy.
This is my lazy picture. Data is a
metaphor for me. You know, I'm like very
lazy, and I want I want to do this
without the the effort of having to
design controllers and um algorithms per
domain, right?
And so, you know, that kind of took us
from robotics 1.0, which is the
sense-plan-act paradigm, um to robotics
2.0, right? Which is uh what you'd often
refer to as end-to-end learning or robot
learning or data-driven robot learning,
right? And the idea being you kind of
remove a lot of those components and go
from uh perception to control. And so,
you go from like your input sensors out
to
um
out to controls that you can run on your
robot, right? And typically, you'll
represent this with a big neural network
um that you will train with lots and
lots and lots of data.
And so, um this sounds like a great
principle, right? Like it's worked so
well for us in other domains of life,
but in robotics, it's not going to be
that simple to actualize. And so, uh a
lot of this talk is going to be about
how to actualize the principle of
end-to-end robot learning.
Also, if anyone has any questions,
please interrupt me.
Happy to happy to stop.
Okay. So, you maybe to understand what
it takes to actualize uh robot learning
um with lots of data, it's useful to
look at what has happened in other
domains, right? So, let's look at things
like language or vision, right? Um
And you see that there's been this order
of magnitude growth from like tiny data
sets like MNIST to ImageNet to LAION or
um you know, like Twitter sentiments
data set, which is a tiny data set
couple couple tens of thousands to like
common crawl which is trillions of
tokens.
And
um there's of course been a growth but
an important thing in that growth is
that it's been passive, right? So the
growth has not been someone goes out and
like manually types in a bunch of
sentences. A lot of this has come from
from the web scale and that's because
people are using the internet anyways
and so this data is going to grow
anyways, right?
And so uh the question is can we do that
for robotics?
Now the tricky thing about robotics is
that there's not that many robots
deployed
um in real diverse applications and so
there's not like this passive data
stream, right? So there's no data that
is just coming in because people are
using robots anyways.
And so a paradigm that's become uh you
know more popular in recent years is
that of teleoperation, right? So you
have these interesting teleoperation
devices. This one's called the UMi.
There's others which are based on VR,
right? And so you have uh these types of
ways of collecting data which are better
than what we had before.
Um but they're still not passive, right?
And so you still have to go into the
field and you have to collect all this
data and you have to put in all this
effort and you have to take your data
collection device or your robot to K
different environments and and that
takes a lot of money and resources and
time, right? And so
um
if we had to cover things at the scale
that things uh have been covered for
vision and language, um
then I think this becomes a proposition
that I certainly don't have funding for.
Right? And so
uh what we've been thinking about is can
we use cheaper sources of data that
might still be useful um but might be a
little lower quality in some ways.
So specifically we've been thinking
about the idea of off-domain data,
right? So off-domain data um I mean data
sets that are
relevant to robotics but are not
literally on a robot, right? So for
instance data generated through
generative models, data like like
large-scale video
um and specifically the focus of today's
discussion will be data from simulation,
right?
And so, um an important thing to note up
front is that off-domain data is wrong
data. It's never going to be as good as
your data on a robot collected by some,
you know, high-quality expert operator.
But, it can still be useful. And then,
today we're going to try and think about
specifically about simulation and
whether simulation data can be made
useful for robots.
Right. So, so why simulation? And
simulation, um you know, um people are
pouring billions of dollars into
simulation, and simulation has some
fundamental advantages, right? So, um
for instance, the data is a lot cheaper
in principle cuz you're spending
computer on it, not actual um man hours.
Um you have privileged information. You
know where everything is. You know where
the forces are. Um you have simple
resets, and because you know where
everything is, you might be able to
define rewards easily. Um and you can go
much faster than real time, right? You
can leverage all the advantages of
largely parallel computation. And that's
led to a lot of the advantage advances
that are coming um in, for instance,
humanoids or legged robots, uh a lot of
them out of ETH, right? Um are coming
um because of these advantages of
simulation.
But, I want to highlight a specific term
here, a specific term of like it's only
cheaper data in principle.
And when you actually get
[clears throat] down to the the brass
tacks of trying to get simulation to
work for um robots, especially robot
manipulation, there's a lot of hidden
cost. And today we're going to try and
tackle some of that hidden cost.
So, what is this hidden cost, right? So,
when I think about, you know, I want to
put a robot into an environment, I want
to use simulation to let's say generate
data or to simplify this robot learning
process,
um it's not as simple as, you know, uh
me as a human says, "Give me data in
this environment." It's more a process
of you start off with designing and
creating an environment. So, some
artists, often a PhD student or
someone professional, would go in and
create an environment in Blender, right?
So, they go in and they edit things,
they drag things around, they adjust the
physics, they adjust the the geometries
until something looks good, right?
Um and now they have an environment, but
that took them many many many hours to
create.
Now when they have an environment, then
they need to go actually get robots to
do things in that environment, right?
So, they have to find ways to like
either they collect data in that
environment or generate data in that
environment and uh for difficult
contacted problems, that is also an
endeavor of many many many hours.
Okay, now you've like generated this
data and then you realize, "Hey, my like
simulator doesn't quite match the real
world." And so, if the simulator doesn't
match the real world, then I go and like
tweak my simulator, I fix these
parameters, I fix these things, and I
identify the system, and only then is
the simulator effective um in the real
world, right?
And so, remember, I'm a lazy potato. I
don't work, right? Um and I don't want
to do complex engineering per domain.
So, all of this work that went from, you
know, the vision of generating data in a
domain to like actually generating data
and using it for a particular domain is
way too much uh for my lazy potato. And
I want to find a way to kind of automate
these pieces so I can uh learn with as
little effort as possible, right? So, um
simulation gives us the premise of
having less cost of data, but it doesn't
really um account for the effort in
actually designing those simulations and
getting it to work. And so, today we're
going to try and remove that effort.
Okay.
Um so, the three sections we'll talk
about really quickly are um starting by
generating simulation environments from
real data, then trying to generate
behavior cheaply in those simulations
through reinforcement learning, and
lastly is adapting to the real world
with minimum amounts of effort.
So, let's let's get started.
So, the the first thing that we started
thinking about is okay, every time you
have to create an environment, we have
to spend all of this effort and a lot of
it is manual design, right? Um and and
what we wanted to do instead was kind of
use some of the advantage advances in
generative AI to um automatically
generate fully articulated interactive
simulation scenes from images or videos,
right? And so, we've been calling this
real to sim. Uh but the idea is that,
you know, a student here goes into the
the kitchen, um grabs a short video of
the scene, all right? And out comes not
just a static mesh, uh but really a
fully interactive kitchen scene, right?
So, all the objects are movable, the
microwaves and the cabinets and the
dishwasher. Um and really you want to be
able to interact with that scene fully
so that you can do, you know, evaluation
or data generation or um
gaming applications with these kinds of
environments, right? And so, um the idea
here is that we're not scaling with
human effort, you're just scaling with,
you know, videos or images that you
collect in the environment.
And the idea here is that you would
produce something that is representative
of that environment, not just a generic
kitchen.
So, um
I won't have enough time to go deep into
the details here, but the fundamental
premise is we use some of the advances
in 3D vision, specifically Gaussian
splatting, and then use some of the
advances in in foundation models, uh
specifically grounded SAM and at the
time GPT-4, in order to get interaction,
right? So, you can think of Gaussian
splatting as a way to go from uh visuals
of a scene, so like multi-view images of
a scene or videos, um
to high-fidelity meshes and visuals,
right? So, you can like think of the the
visuals you see on the left as basically
all just coming directly from raw camera
capture, right? Um and so, you you can
reconstruct and get novel views, but the
nice part is that you can also get um
you know, underlying geometries. And the
the the tricky part is tying the visuals
to the geometries so that they're align.
Um and then once you have this, you can
then think, okay, there's like these
cabinets. You can separate out the
cabinets. You can figure out, are they
cabinets? Are they drawers? Are they
dishwashers? Are they fridges? And then
you can try and articulate them, right?
So, you can put on like hinges and
joints and so on. Um and then you kind
of go back and forth in this process of
you a few times to get it interactive
scene.
Um
and what this kind of results in is if
you go to a bunch of different kitchens,
you apply the same procedure, and you go
straight from videos to fully
interactive kitchen scenes, right? So,
there this was no effort. It was just
compute, right? You go in with a video,
and out comes a fully interactive scene
that looks just like the scene that you
you recorded, but it's fully interactive
with the physics simulation.
Um so, that's pretty cool. Um
and what do what do we do with this,
right? Why do we care? We're we're
roboticists.
So, the first and simplest thing to do
is you can use it for data generation,
right? So, you want to like, for
instance, learn to like open a drawer or
put a cup in it, close the drawer, etc.
Now, you have a simulation, and you can
use all the nice tools we have in
simulation to generate data, and we'll
talk a bunch about this in the second
section.
Um but one point that I want to
highlight is that simulation offers a
really nice tool for evaluation, right?
So, like
uh uh big challenge in real world robots
is that it's hard to evaluate. It's hard
to know whether you're successful or
when you're not successful, right? And
well, because you have to like have a
human in the environment running trials
over and over and over and over. So,
every new algorithm that you come up
with, it's a huge process to actually
evaluate.
Um but one of the nice things about
these highly photo realistic realistic
simulations is that you can just run
evaluations directly in simulation, even
for controllers that you trained in the
real world, right?
And so, what we what we kind of did with
these tools that we built was we said,
"Hey, we're going to construct these
scenes, right? So, these scenes are uh
two scenes that we've constructed in
simulation. So, these look like the real
world, but they're actually just scenes
in simulation, right? You can see like
if you want to see it simulation, you
can see like tiny little artifacts on
the arm
or like on the side over here,
but I promise you they're simulation. Um
and once you have that, you can then say
I can take your policies or foundation
models and things that I trained in the
real world and then transfer them back
into simulation, right? And so then you
can
construct evaluation scenes. So these
are a few different scenes at University
of Washington and Princeton um and we're
able to transfer them directly from the
real world back into simulation. And
because they're hyperrealistic
um and visually really realistic and the
physics is good, um you can actually run
these policies directly in simulation
with high degrees of correlation.
And so here we're running uh these
policies from this company Physical
Intelligence um
and so they have these policies that
were not trained on any simulated data,
mostly on real world data, but you can
kind of get them from the real world
back into simulation so you can run lots
and lots and lots of evaluation.
And so what's nice about this is that
you can then like you want your things
to be close to the diagonal, right? So
you want there's these two measures of
Pearson correlation and MMRV, which is
rank violation. You want Pearson to be
high and rank violation to be low and
you can see that it's like pretty well
correlated, but not perfect between sim
and real.
And the important thing is not that you
get the behavior exactly to be the same,
but really that you can see things that
are better in simulation would also be
better in the real world. Right? And
there was no way to get here unless you
had hyperrealistic simulation. So
um
when we we tried doing this on far less
realistic scenes, it worked a lot worse.
And so you do have to do a little bit of
magic there, so you know, it's not just
zero-zero shot, you have to add in a
little bit of simulation data into the
training mixture.
Right? But it's like you add a little
bit of simulation data, the models adapt
to the general idea of simulation, and
then you can evaluate it on new
problems.
Uh but the important thing is that um
we were able to construct these
environments for data generation and
evaluation just by taking in videos
without like a ton of effort in creating
any of the scenes. So, it's like a it's
gone from a several days effort to a
several minutes effort.
And so, if you think about the takeaways
here, um it's basically that there's no
more uh manual environment design. I'm
happy I don't have to do the work of
doing it and and that's good. Have fun
with that.
Okay.
So, so that's first uh creating
environments uh in simulation without
the pain, right? But, we are
roboticists, we want behavior, right? We
want robots that are flipping and
jumping and doing manipulation and and
building things, right? And so, um we
will want to actually generate behavior.
And to generate behavior, you have to go
a step beyond creating the environment.
And so, um there's lots of different
ways to do it, but two of the tools that
people often use are human data
collection. So, someone will hop into
like a VR interface or some track glove
and then try to control robots to do
things and you can do this in
simulation, too.
Or someone goes in and uses tools like
reinforcement learning, but writes down
like a fancy reward function, right? So,
here's a snapshot from one of the reward
functions that uh folks have used and
you can see that has like a ton of
little terms with these random
weightings and these like arbitrary
designs.
And so,
um
it's it's often a pretty painstaking
process, right? And me as a as a lazy
potato doesn't want to do that, right? I
don't want to go in and collect data and
I don't want to sit and have to design
these environments and these reward
functions and stuff with reinforcement
learning. And so,
um my goal is to find a way to generate
really, you know, high coverage robust
data in simulation, but without the
pain.
And and so, um my students Tyler and
Patrick asked, "Can we we RL in
simulation without the pain?" And so,
they wanted to perform uh behavior
generation, which is physically accurate
in simulation, but without
demonstrations, without reward design,
and they kind of leverage the fact that
simulation is not reality, right? So,
simulation and reality are not the same
thing. And specifically, um simulation
has some privileges that might make your
problem of behavior generation easier
than the real world, right? So,
specifically, we have resets, you have
privileged information, you have cheap
samples, right? And so, we're going to
use these different privileged
informations to make our job easier.
Specifically, we're going to focus in on
the idea of resets. When I say resets, I
mean I can set the simulator wherever I
want, right? I can't teleport the real
world anywhere, but I can teleport the
simulation to anywhere,
And so, um what we're going to try and
do is try to generate behavior, uh but
without any of the pain of
demonstrations or reward design. We're
going to use resets to do so.
And so, the key idea
um that we're going to leverage is that
resets can make exploration easier. So,
the hard part about reinforcement
learning is often you're like exploring
the world, you're trying random stuff,
and you have to like it's a needle in a
haystack problem, right? So, imagine
your goal was in the green star, you
started over on the left. Now, you have
to like try a bunch of random stuff
until you like accidentally hit the
goal, right? And that is a huge pain,
takes a huge amount of compute, and
that's often what you use the reward
design to do is to like direct the way
you're searching, right?
And so, if I'm always starting at the
starting point, imagine I'm like
wiggling my arm randomly, like I have to
randomly chance upon the green star. And
that is kind of a pain.
But, the idea behind using resets is
that I don't have to start at the first
point anymore, I can reset myself all
the way to the last point, right? And
then I'm solving a much easier problem.
It's like imagine I reset right next to
the target, I'm solving a much easier
problem. Then I reset one step away,
then I reset two steps away, then I
reset three steps away, right? And so,
if I'm am to use the fact that I can
teleport in my simulation, um I can get
behavior a lot more easily cuz I'm only
solving easy short horizon problems.
And so, um the idea that uh my students
Patrick and Tyler kind of took is that
if you can reset really really broadly
in a simulation, so these are some of
the examples of reset states. You can
see there's like partially assembled
partial assemblies, partial grasp,
resetting the arm all over the place,
right? Um if you can do that, um then
you can get your reinforcement to learn
behaviors uh without any fancy reward
design, with only sparse rewards, with
no demonstrations. Um and you can
generate these programmatically, right?
So, the idea is that you don't you use
the fact that you have privileged resets
in simulation and you just reset all
over the place. And then you run
reinforcement learning starting from all
of those places.
Right? And so, um
let me
skip through the next part, maybe. But,
um what results from this large-scale
reinforcement learning, right, is this
kind of behavior um that you get without
any demonstrations. This is not provided
by a human. This is only with a sparse
reward. Um and uh you can see that it
has like lots of interesting
non-prehensile adjustment behavior that
you'd expect from a human, like re-
rearrangement, wiggling, uh flipping,
right? Um you can like do furniture
assembly. You can see that it like lifts
things over, uses the side of objects to
do like non-prehensile and interesting
manipulation.
Um but, the cool thing is it's the exact
same code for both tasks. The only thing
you did is you provided them um the CAD
models, and it's exactly the same code,
no reward design, no demonstrations,
right? You can apply this across many
many many tasks. Doesn't work for every
single problem, but works for a large
range of these contact-rich tasks and
works for any way.
Right? So, if you um if you're the lazy
potato like me, uh you think about,
"Okay, I don't want to collect more and
more, more data. So, is this thing
really robust? Uh And you can see that
like if you had collected data, it's
hard to see, but you can see these a few
green axes on this middle plot.
Whereas if you do this like really broad
reset, you get success anywhere. So, you
can place it anywhere and it'll assemble
the table for you.
Right? And so, you can take this a step
further and you can go and assemble a
table with with four legs or you can do
like other tasks like picking and
placing and
you know, like I find the one on the
bottom right really interesting cuz
you're like trying to like rearrange
this block against this table, but you
can see that it like learns to use the
environment in interesting ways. And so,
um the cool part here is all of it is
emergent, right? None of it is like hand
coded. Um all of it is just emergent
from large-scale reinforcement learning.
Okay. So,
um the important takeaway here is that
if you use the privileges of simulation,
it allows for lots of cheap and robust
data generation, but you have to be
careful in how exactly you use that
simulation, right? And so, for my lazy
potato though, it's it's taken me away
from environment design and now it's
taken me away from reward design, right?
So, I'm way happier. I'm able to get
behavior in simulation without the pain.
Okay.
And then the last section
is around
is around real world deployment. Like
we're roboticists, we care about the
real world, right? We want robots to do
things in the real world.
And simulation is inherently wrong,
right? So, if simulation and reality
were compared, they're inherently wrong.
The physics is wrong, the visuals are a
little wrong and I could go within and I
could adjust the sim and the real the
sim to match reality more. I could
identify things perfectly, and but that
makes me unhappy cuz I'm lazy. And so,
I could of course spend more time making
simulation accurate, but what I'm going
to do instead is I'm going to try and
improve autonomously in in real world
without putting in effort. So, I'm going
to try and see can I run an algorithm
autonomously in the real world to go
from the behavior on the left, which is
failing, to the behavior on the right,
which is successful,
um without putting in lots of effort,
right?
And and the important thing to think
about here is what simulation is wrong,
but it's still useful for certain
things, right? So, for instance,
simulation is good at capturing the
global strategy of a problem, right? If
I have to pick up a leg and insert it
and rotate it, um
it kind of captures that global
structure just fine. What it sometimes
struggles with is getting the exact
physics a little bit wrong, right? So,
like if you're getting the forces a
little bit wrong or the contacts a
little bit wrong. Um and so, what we're
going to do is we're going to try and
like cover global planning uh or like
the global structure of the problem from
simulation, and then we're going to try
and fix the local acting from the real
world. So, we're going to capture the
big long long structure of the problem
from sim, and fix the little bits of uh
of detail from from real data, right?
I'm largely going to skip through the
details here, but essentially we kind of
use world models to do this, like
like you've seen a lot of these tools in
um in the uh AI literature of like
dynamics models or predictive models of
the future. And so, we're going to try
and uh cast this as a world modeling
problem, but we're going to try and um
freeze some of the long horizon parts of
the problem from simulation, and only
adjust the short horizon prediction
parts from the real world, right?
And so, the paradigm we're going to take
is pre-train a lot in pre-train a world
model in simulation, and just adjust
little parts of it in the real world,
right?
Um and since we're a little short on
time, let's let's let's get straight to
the results, but you can see what
happens is that, you know, if you
transfer things from simulation to
reality, at first, you see that it's not
quite that wrong, but it gets a little
bit of the details wrong, which makes it
hard to like insert the leg properly.
But if you adjust uh with little bits of
uh real data autonomously, you you get
like full furniture assembly that looks
something like that, right?
And so the point here is that I didn't
have to put in any effort. The algorithm
ran autonomously and fixed itself.
Um you can do similar things for um
other tasks, too. Again, all the tasks
that you see um were transferred
directly and they don't work, but if you
if you transfer them and adjust a little
bit, um it gets a lot better. So, like
interesting things to see here is that
it like learns how to like flip up the
object and like do pretty interesting
dynamic motions. Um
just by little bits of real world data.
You can also apply this to like other
problems like quadrupeds and so on. And
the interesting thing is it like fixes
those little physics mistakes, but it
captures the general structure of
walking pretty well in simulation.
Okay. So, the important part here is
that we can make real world adaptation a
lot easier through simulation. So,
simulation is not a silver bullet, but
it can make real world adaptation super
fast and super easy. So, within 15
minutes of data collection.
So, um the last bit is I don't have to
go and fix my simulation and and bridge
this sim-to-real gap um
as a human, I just allow the data to do
it, right?
And so the important thing here is that
simulation can be a good way to scale up
data for robotics,
but it's all about managing costs,
right? So, managing costs and managing
effort. And so you want to do that while
representing the diversity of the data.
And so that's going to make you or me as
a lazy potato happy. That's actually our
goal in life.
Um these are the papers we covered um
and the students who worked on it.
Yeah, thanks for your attention.
>> [applause]
>> Abhishek, can you hear me?
Um thank you very much for the talk. And
uh to anyone in the audience who has to
go, you can go, but whoever has
questions, we're happy to um take them.
So, just raise is a hand.
Uh thank you for the talk. Um just a a
question on the resetting paper um where
you leverage the fact that you're able
to reset in simulation environments um
but but not in the real world.
How how do you define for for different
tasks? We saw We saw one example where
you're uh doing a construction, so you
might for example have um different
parts of it already assembled. Uh but
have you thought about for for uh other
types of tasks, how you define closeness
um for your for your problem, and how do
you avoid uh when defining closeness a
bias uh let's say towards
learning a a particular policy um
because of that inherent definition of
of closeness or that's biased towards
it.
Oh, you you might have to repeat that
for me cuz of the audio.
Um
uh
Good.
I heard something about how do you
define the reset state, but I like
missed a bunch of the details, sorry.
All right.
Let's use this mic. Okay. Okay, good.
Sorry, thank [laughter] you.
So yeah, that's good.
>> Okay, we're going to we're going to try
again. Uh can you hear me now?
Okay.
Yes? Yes, that's perfect. Yeah. Great.
Uh so the the question is just um
when it comes to resetting in the
simulation environment, how do you
define for different tasks what it means
to be close uh to the end state? We We
saw one example there with uh
constructing materials, um but for other
tasks I can imagine that you might
induce, depending on your definition, a
a bias towards um
towards your learning.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. No, that's a great
question. Um so what we did is we we
applied it to some general class of
assembly problems, right? So we want to
like insert the drawer, or assemble the
leg, right? And so,
um the way we did is we assumed that the
the user provides you with a full
assembly looks like, like a like a
complete assembly, and then we kind of
went backwards from there. So, you like
start from the complete assembly, and
then you start adding a small amounts of
noise to your policy,
um and that gets you to like near
assembly states.
Um I think a a relatively general way of
doing at least assembly problems is this
assembly through disassembly paradigm.
Like, you take a fully assembled thing,
and you start to disassemble it, and
that gives you some nearby states, but I
think it's a pretty open question how
you do this for the broader class of any
problem.
It's a good good question. Cool.
Uh one more question there.
Hi. Thank you for the talk. Um so,
for the real to same part, you showed
that you were collecting data from the
real world and articulating it in
simulation, which was very cool.
I was wondering if you think that there
would be a way to also capture the
physical properties of those objects and
try to bring them into simulation. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's a great
question. Um
so, we've tried this uh a couple of
times, uh like figuring out the like
physical properties of like friction, or
softness, or damping, or things like
that. Um and so, like you can kind of
poke around with the world and like use
that data to set the properties.
Um
what we found is that
often
it is less effective to do that than it
is to just choose a reasonable range of
parameters in simulation, and just train
a policy that's robust or adapted to
those parameters. So, I think um
um at least in the the the task we've
considered, which in the first part are
not that dynamic, um it hasn't made that
big of a difference, but there's lots of
interesting ways to do system
identification of objects and physics
parameters that you can try, but um
I think it's an open question on which
problems does it make a big difference.
Yeah, that's a good question.
Okay. Uh thank you so much.
Uh
what
Do you have time for one more question
or
Yeah? Yeah, of course. Okay. Yeah. Can
we take the the mic so the others hear?
Okay.
We'll figure out the mic situation for
next time.
Okay, so my question is um for the
reconstruction actually um
how do you
um guarantee that it's that it's robust
enough because like I imagine you just
do it with a iPhone, right?
It has like depth cameras and lidars
inside of it, but like with other phones
you probably can't do it yet.
And also for the object detection No.
and segmentation Uh-huh.
how can you guarantee that it's actually
like correctly detects affordances?
It's kind of vague to me, honestly.
Yeah.
It's a It's an interesting question. Um
so
the in from the iPhone we don't actually
use anything except for the camera
images. So we don't actually use the
depth and we don't use the lidar and
stuff.
Um so I guess with these Gaussian
planning techniques it's um
just just from raw camera images and use
this technique called COLMAP to figure
out where all the cameras